أحب العودة إلى جبال روكي للتزلج
في جبال روكي على عكس
أي شيء جربته من قبل ، مثل أنه
يقويك بالتأكيد إنه بارد إنه
متين ، إنه شديد الانحدار لدينا
تضاريس مذهلة هنا ، لذلك يجبرك حقًا أن
تكون في لعبتك وأنا  أعتقد أن
نشأتي هنا هو ما جعلني حقًا متزلجًا
[موسيقى]
يقع BAMF في حديقة وطنية جميلة في
ألبرتا بكندا ، وهو محاط
بزاوية 360 درجة من الجبال وهو
المكان الأكثر روعة الذي زرته في العالم
هذا تل رائع جدًا ، نعم أنت
تعرف أن الأطفال يتعلمون كيفية التزلج ومن
ثم بالنسبة للمآثر ، نعم
حول كل شيء هناك الكثير من الأشخاص
في هذا المجتمع الذين يعيشون فقط
للجبال ويعيشون من أجل تلك
البيئة وأنت تأخذ شخصًا مثل ليو يبلغ من العمر 87 عامًا
عمري 26 عامًا
ولدينا الكثير من القواسم المشتركة بناءً
على حبنا للجبال ،
يقع متجر عائلتي في شارع بانف مباشرة
يسمى manone sports وقد
بدأ جدي في عام 1949 وكان كذلك  في
العائلة منذ أن كانت هذه هي الصفقة الحقيقية
هنا ، هذا يشبه جدار تراث العائلة ،
لذا يبدأ هنا في جدي
ينزل إلى خالتي وهي في
فريق التزلج الكندي ، والدي عمدة
في فريق التزلج الكندي ثم  لقد
بنى أبي هذا الضريح الصغير من أجلي وهو أمر
محرج حقًا ولكني أتزلج من أجل
لقمة العيش الممتعة والجميع يقول دائمًا ،
أنت محظوظ جدًا ولديك
أمر سهل للغاية ولكن مع ما أفعله لا
يأتي بدون مخاطر والإصابة  جزء كبير
من ذلك وهذا شيء
كنت أتعامل معه الآن لمدة تسعة أشهر
بعد أن مررت بحادث تصادم سيئ حقًا
في ألاسكا ،
يعد BAMF مجرد مجتمع مترابط
أشعر أنه عندما يكون هناك
حادث أو يحدث خطأ ما
للجميع  مسيرات العودة معًا
إلى الفرقة بعد أن كان الحادث هو
الخيار الوحيد ، كل ما أردت القيام به هو
المكان الذي تكون فيه عائلتي أصدقائي
نظام الدعم الخاص بي وهم جيدون جدًا في رفع مستوى
وحتى المرور بإصابتي ،
لقد كان لدي الكثير من الحب.  و sup  ميناء
من المجتمع هنا
[تصفيق]
أنا محظوظ جدًا وأدرك أنه على
وجه الخصوص عندما أغادر بانف ، أدرك
كم أنا محظوظ لكوني منهم